hi everybody matt luigi here this video
is about the youtube channel the one you
were watching and not any game or game
aspect so i'll try to be quick as most
of you probably watch my channel for
elden ring lore and not creator updates
if this were the youtube of ten five or
even three years ago i would have to
make a whole long intro about how the
youtube algorithm doesn't reward quality
and as such needs to be supplemented by
outside support how creators are forced
to turn their content into high octane
clickbait to make sure their channel
stays on the good side of the variable
code of youtube engineers but this isn't
2014 youtube so i can say right away
that i've made a patreon this video will
be a talk about a channel update which
is the inclusion of patreon as a way to
support the channel and my work when i
make these videos i have to do so in the
free time i have outside of my full-time
job this plus the problems of youtube
revenue being inconsistent and youtube
rewarding clickbait spam as opposed to
spaced out quality means that there is
little chance of turning this into
something full time if i only rely on
youtube ad revenue if i could do youtube
full time i would be able to take more
time making each video as well as making
more videos at a faster rate
theoretically i should be able to
increase video quality and quantity
though quality would take precedence and
certainly be able to be increased in a
nutshell that is the update and
justification i would like to be able to
focus on this channel more and make
better content i would be able to do so
if it delivered a more stable and
substantial income so i am opening a
patreon where people who enjoy my work
can choose to support it if they wish to
there will be some perks that come along
with pledging support such as seeing
scripts before videos come out getting
name shoutouts at the end of videos and
getting to send in questions for future
q a's there is a good chance that i will
modify or expand these perks in the
future i could include seeing videos
early for example but for now that's
going to be what the perks are and i
should stress that they are perks the
main purpose for pledging being
supporting the channel and not getting
these perks obviously this will be
completely voluntary and all of my
videos will still be available to watch
for free on my channel this is a way for
those who can and wish to support the
channel to do so if you think i make
quality content and you would like to
see more of it then please consider
becoming a patron if i can get enough
patron support i can turn this into
either a more proper part-time thing or
possibly even a full-time job the more
time i can spend on this the better
videos i can make and the more regularly
i can keep making these videos when
eldon ring came out i had to limit a lot
of outside life stuff to focus on making
the videos and even then i still only
had a few significant videos out during
that month i don't know how consistently
i can even match that pace of content
especially for new releases like
potential future dlc this announcement
would be an avenue to better that
situation and make it more possible for
me to deliver that quality content with
more consistent regularity well i feel
like i've delivered the main point and
repeated myself a little bit so i'll
conclude the video here the main idea is
basic if patreon support materializes
the channel's content should get better
if you would like to support that you
can become a patron i have a few
different tiers so you can commit to
support any amount that seems right for
you and on a similar note as of now i
haven't taken any sponsorships on this
channel and i will announce if that is
going to change i imagine that this may
be likely in addition to the patreon to
make the channel something i can
consider a part-time or full-time thing
but that will depend on how much support
the patreon brings in
so thank you for watching all this way
if you have let me know in the comments
if you have any questions about the
patreon the content or the channel in
general i'm excited by the recent uptick
in the channel with eldon ring and hope
to keep things moving and growing with
more content and branching out into
additional kinds of videos such as ones
that look at the philosophy present in
games or other deep dives that won't
necessarily generate a ton of views but
will still be worthwhile content that
people on my channel will want to see
the main idea of the patreon is
basically to support this that i can
make more videos better videos and
videos that aren't beholden to the
algorithm of youtube better videos might
not be ones that would necessarily get a
lot more views
so i hope you enjoyed the video this
should be the last scheduled one that
i've made so the next video you see me
in will likely be a more substantial
video on elden ring an elden ring lore
game mechanics or something like that
i'll see you in that video and thanks
for being patient as i take some time
off peace